um how did you guys get started i think
it was it was first fighting then it was
the um webcam girls
look uh webcam girls were reminding
andrew's big break and you can't make it
wasn't fighting
no i mean fighting makes some money and
andrew especially was a very successful
kickboxer four-time world champion his
belts are sitting right behind me right
now yeah but you know the most he ever
got paid for a fight and he says this
openly is 50 grand by the time you pay
your trainer and your manager 10 each
you got to eat you got trained for 12
weeks i mean if you look at the hours
you put in you're making 15 bucks an
hour like it's it's not amazing money
right and um but but kickboxing and
being who we were physically and we're
always very very out there we're always
very good with women that's what
helped us because you can't just come
along and start a webcam studio women
aren't just going to go oh yeah i'll
come get naked at your house for money
like and and keep in mind that the women
that we hire from for webcam modeling
people are disillusioned they think that
like i
drive around the streets the avenues and
pick girls up off the boulevard and say
come on i'm rescuing you you're doing
this now i mean i'm talking
girls who worked in stores my best ever
girl used to work in a bathroom store
selling toilets and baths and showers
like normal ass girls
and to convince them about that you went
in to get towels or something like that
and you saw her and you just started
chatting her up
later one of your girls
sometimes yes not with that one
particularly but you find one on dating
apps and just the same way you'd hit up
any normal girl because when we started
the studio
broke or not it's why i don't accept
people saying women only like you
because you're rich yeah some women are
attracted to the fun lifestyle i have
but when i was flat broke me and andrew
had lots of girlfriends each and we told
all of them okay now your webcam models
and half of them broke up with us half
of them left straight away and the other
half became our first batch of webcam
girls and a couple years later we were
millionaires so that was certainly
financially our big break and then it
takes money to make money they say we've
done plenty of other things since making
our first million that have put us on
bugatti money so aside from aside from
the webcam girls um
what else contributed to
the bugatti money like the biggest uh
the big things you know what i i won't i
won't say the two biggest things i won't
say the two biggest things but the third
biggest thing
was cryptocurrency and it wasn't that i
was one of these guys with so much
foresight and so of so much genius and
so much tech uh savvy intellect that i
was like oh this cryptocurrency it's
amazing it's good it's that i just liked
how easy it was so i was buying bitcoin
when they were three thousand dollars
with my webcam money tens of thousands
of dollars of bitcoin my net worth would
be
half of what it is
if i'd never invested in cryptocurrency
but at the time i didn't see it as an
investment
i was in a world where the people i was
dealing with took crypto it was easier
for me to take their crypto than to take
big bank payments
and
it just all fell into place so that that
certainly doubled my my lender's net
worth
but anyone who knows anyone who knows
anything about us would can do the math
and work that out yeah and um
you guys have dabbled in
not just bitcoin but quite a few other
cryptocurrencies too right oh and yeah
when i say bitcoin i mean cryptocurrency
as a whole i'm keeping it simple for
that but but it but inside of i'm
telling you inside of the war room some
of the calls that have been made inside
of the war room i mean if you look up
solana it's a cryptocurrency i had never
heard of
what did you get on that i got in at
nine dollars
and one of the guys who you know had had
read the white paper i was like
that one yeah exactly he shielded inside
the war room that mean that made me
half the half the money of a bugatti as
it is just that one how do you so so let
me ask you this question for the people
watching um because i think this is a
good
you know conversation piece how do you
establish
where to go pile in money when it comes
to cryptocurrency because i mean
you don't dick around with like you know
throw a thousand at this and three
thousand at that it's like okay you want
to make i'm assuming like game changing
money you want to turn 50 grand into a
million dollars right like how do you
how do you decide where to because you
know 50 grand for anybody especially
somebody that was not born with a silver
spoon or their mouths like you guys you
know at some point i'm sure you both
remember being poor right of course how
do you how do you decide where to throw
like you know 50 grand into like how do
you
i'll be on the risk
i'll be perfectly honest and this is and
i i will i will happily happily give all
the credit to some of the guys inside of
the war
we have a dedicated crypto room in there
for those who don't know who the war
room is it's a it's a let's let's say
it's a network it's a networking
organization that is owned by my brother
i'm just a member like like anybody else
but there's a crypto room in there with
some of the smartest crypto mine uh
mines
uh in the world people who launch icos
people who launch their own coins people
who are huge
in uh in the mining industry uh guys in
texas who you know are some of the
biggest bitcoin miners in the united
states i'm not gonna say any of their
names but they they exist inside of the
war room and when they say i believe in
this coin because x y and z here is its
use case here is this i'd advise going
in i'm now at the financial level well i
can literally just read that and say
okay let's go in 100k 150 200k went i
went in recently and uh i don't know how
badly this is going to age uos ultra
your worst uos ultra they some my friend
had heard that bethesda game studio had
teamed up with them and that was going
to be the token used in inside of
bethesda's games and even i who don't
play video games know who but there's
the game studios are so i went in i went
in for 200k
just recently and and and crypto's
dipped now but it's still worth 220. 20k
where do you um
like hold your
crypto to deal with minimizing tax
liabilities like is romania a well
friendly uh
well i would never discuss how i hold my
crypto on the internet because it's just
bad practice yeah like i'm not saying
the public information but like you know
country wise for like tax liability
reasons although i i with the crypto i
have with
in romania i have i have actual
businesses i own casinos i pay all the
taxes that are necessary for my casinos
the romanian government and the tax
authorities are all very happy with me
everything is completely above board but
i will say publicly right here right now
i store my crypto in a way nobody can
steal it so if anyone's watching this
thinking oh this guy has a bunch of
crypto let me find out this about him
you're not going to find my crypto
anywhere so it's all very safely stored
you know you need physical keys and you
need to go to physical banks to get hold
of my crypto so
yeah i'll just put that out there in
case anyone gets any smart ideas do you
think that it's the best store of value
today
um i think it's the
easiest store of value i think that if
you're i think i think if you're a kid
and you're uh you know you have a few
thousand bucks and you're living in the
middle of wisconsin somewhere where the
[ __ ] you gonna go and buy gold from
like where where's the where's the gold
store in wisconsin where you're gonna go
buy three thousand dollars with a gold
then what are you gonna do hide it under
your bed at your mother's house
like anybody could set up some
two-factor authentications and some
little wallets et cetera on their phone
or their device from home and be very
very safe and purchase crypto hold it
sell it out when they need to it's the
easiest store value and then they can
send it across the world they can send
it to china in one second 10 million
dollars if they want to yeah so it's uh
you see it as a as a currency or do you
see it as a like uh michael saylor calls
it uh digital real estate now i don't
know if you heard it yeah breakdown i
have i have i have uh me i can't see it
as anything but money because i use it
as money i use it as money i mean i mean
this
in places like dubai where they will
they'll take crypto i this watch was
literally bought with crypto i literally
sent them i don't know it was bitcoin
and ethereum i can't even remember or i
sold it for usd tether i think and just
send them usdt for the us dollar value
of the watch and then i wouldn't pick up
the watch i use it as money so i can't
see it as anything but money gotcha yeah
on savile row takes takes bitcoin
yeah
take bitcoin yeah if you're not taking
payment from your customers and
cryptocurrency like bitcoin or ether you
guys are losing out definitely
definitely consider that
um random question tristan what's your
hair loss protocol are you for or
against finasteride mad respect to you
and andrew i don't i don't even know
what finasteride is my friend i don't
know
that's the pill that you pop that lowers
your dhc that's supposed to keep your
hair from falling out
no idea never never heard of it i i'm
all i'm pro
anybody doing anything they like as long
as it isn't
a lazy way of doing things i mean if
guys get like those those implants in
their biceps to make their arms look
bigger i think that's gay you should be
doing some training if your hair is fine
falling out do what you want bro i don't
know there are [ __ ] get a transplant
inject your head with the those
php prp prp prp platelet plasma yeah if
your hair is falling out do it do
whatever you want to fix it i mean that
that's on you i don't know i don't care
but i'm very against anything that i
consider cheating that includes steroid
use
you know pectoral implants and [ __ ] to
look like you have muscles but you know
if your hair's going out yeah your teeth
are all missing you know get you know
yeah like i've been vocal on social
media about uh steroid use so i'm on
therapeutic testosterone obviously
because i'm close to 50 and i don't have
the levels that i did in my 20s and i
want to maintain that muscle mass
well that is something i will do when i
get older yeah yeah i was going to ask
you is that something that you would
consider when your natural levels start
to decline and you can cut well like if
you're here
and you're down to here in your 40s what
you can bring yourself up to here and
feel like you feel like you know in your
early 30s like would you do that well
time is the fire in which we all burn
right women get those [ __ ] face lifts
and straighten their faces out and raise
their tits up etc yeah for men as long
as you're maintaining yourself naturally
you know working out in the gym et
cetera there's nothing wrong with
keeping your
testosterone level high and i guess i
don't want to sound i i've been called
an elitist by by friends of mine for
this because i have friends who are you
know now quite jacked little short dudes
they're quite jacked my age etc and i
say yeah steroids are [ __ ] they [ __ ]
with your dick they you know it's not
good to be taking all the stuff you're
taking and they look at me and they said
yeah tristan but you don't understand
because you're huge
and that hits me here because i'm kind
of like
if i were 140 pounds and you know five
foot three would i see things
differently it's easy for me i'm six
foot four i'm 260 pounds like 260.
it was something like that yeah you're a
big boy
yeah so it's very easy for me to be like
oh well don't take steroids etc i just
don't want to do anything that [ __ ]
with my dick i need my dick it makes me
money literally
the women who work for me and make all
this money on owning fans and i'm not
keeping them happy sexually what the
[ __ ] they're just gonna leave and go
work for someone else so yeah i need my
penis to work
you